what do you think about robot would you
ever buy a robot for your home
yes what will it do i'll be a companion
a friend
oh yeah i mean i would like to start
replacing friends and family with robots
immediately
okay i mean truly truly i mean i'm not
even kidding like
i would like to have a thanksgiving with
four robots i'm i'm
dead serious well are they into queuing
on like
uh do the role are the robots when do
the robots start
going crazy that's my question is like
how long do the robots live with me
before they are also a problem
and i got to replace them you know what
i mean you're going to indoctrinate the
wrong
as my the robot's going to call me like
my aunt doesn't talk about coronavirus
for an hour
every morning and tell me everyone in
america who's died of coronavirus
one of the things i enjoy in life is how
terrified
uh people like you i'm a huge fan by the
way
get a robot well i am i'm concerned
about ai
like completely getting rid of the need
for human beings because human beings i
mean
you go out in the street and you go so
few of these people are necessary even
now
even now you look at people and you go
they're hanging on by a thread right
and you can just imagine how many jobs
are going to get replaced
how many industries are going to be
completely remade
with ai and the pace of change worries
me a little bit because we do a very bad
job in this country
of mitigation when we have problems
we don't do a great job we did not great
job with kovid right
we don't do a good job it's just
something we don't do well we kind of
we're good in booms and busts
we're good when it's good and we're
actually we kind of know how to kind of
like
hey we're bottomed out we're like we're
like a gambling addict in this country
we like
we know what it feels like to be outside
of an otb at 9 00 a.m drinking coffee
and smoking cigarettes going
i'm going to build it back and we know
what it's like to win
but trump anything in between it seems
not that great
so to me it feels like are we going to
be able to like
help people that are displaced and that
have their
jobs taken by i mean do you do you not
fear
sort of an uh a world where you have a
lot of you know artificial intelligence
replacing workers and then what happens
there's a lot of fears
around artificial intelligence one of
them is yes displacement of
jobs workers that's technology in
general that's
just uh any kind of new innovations
displaced jobs i'm less worried about
that i'm more worried about other
impacts of artificial intelligence for
example
the nature of our discourse like social
the effects of algorithms
on the way we communicate with each
other the spread of information
uh what that information looks like the
creation of silos all that kind of stuff
i think that would just make worse
the effects that the displacement of
jobs
has i think ultimately i have a hope
that technology creates more
opportunities than it destroys
i hope so too so in that sense ai to me
is uh an exciting possibility but
you know
you